foreign
Detroit hello Jill how are you
hey hi what's up
hi so
um I I am trying to go from Davis to
full on Dave and
um I'm like a Serial entrepreneur so
like I bring in a lot of money a lot of
different ways but my question is
um should I well I'm paying off debt
should I focus on like just the business
I have that makes me money instead of
putting out money for my other
businesses to make money if that makes
sense
how many are making money
so like okay for example I throw like
parties I'm an event planner so I maybe
spend like 1200 but I'll make a couple
Grand
but I don't know if I should be putting
that money out to do that
you spend 1200 and you make thirty two
hundred
profit of a couple Grand
right that's debt you're paying off
every time you do that all right I mean
so profit is profit yeah I mean you're
not you're not spending the money and
it's not coming back it's coming back to
you instantaneously almost isn't it
yeah it comes back to well the daily
party yeah a couple months later yeah
okay so which business is which that
one's not losing money
well I have like I have like
um like social media type stuff and
that's the stuff that doesn't
necessarily make me money right here and
now and then I also do like drawing and
logos and stuff and
that that makes me money when people
like ask for it but I don't know if I
should really get into like the
full-on advertising and content creating
side of things or I should just wait for
all that type of stuff you should you
should wait to expand right now you just
want to do things that make you money so
you get out of baby step too fast
quick as possible right so we can delay
the stuff that you want to maybe expand
one day once we're in a position to do
so
five years from today do you want to be
in the logo business or the event
planning business
do I want to be a number or visit
planning
you want to be an event planning or
logos which one
event planning okay start doing that now
then
quit screwing around with 17 things
you get no power when you don't Focus
I would focus on I'd focus on event
planning and blow it up
put all your time all your energy all
your effort all your creative waking
hours into one thing
uh working three different businesses is
a recipe for getting none of them off
the ground
okay well I also so my main source of
income is actually like grocery delivery
where I do like ship instacart type
things and I'm I make pretty actually
make pretty good money doing that okay
but that's not that's not what we're
talking about that's that's a stop Gap
until the event business gets big enough
that you don't have to do that anymore
right yeah so if you're making a hundred
thousand dollars a year doing event
planning you wouldn't be doing any of
this other crap
very true okay
okay I will do that I'm gonna send you a
copy I'm gonna send you a copy of a
quick read we have
called the momentum theorem
and the momentum theorem is this focused
intensity
over time
multiplied by God creates Unstoppable
momentum
and this book will take you about an
hour and a half to read Max
okay and it explains exactly what this
focused intensity looks like and you
have the exact opposite of that you have
dispersed intensity which has no power
to it
feels like building it the more I feel
powerless light dispersed lights are
room light Focus you can do surgery with
it's called a laser
and I want you to be laser
and you're going to move this business
into the stratosphere when you do
because you got so much energy on you
there's so much joy coming off of you
you you you're like the ultimate event
planner this is going to be great oh
yeah and again you have a side hustle
that's actually spinning off real profit
that's where you put your focus right
now we're trying to generate income to
get out of debt get the emergency fund
in place and that changes your entire
perspective so I mean this is the focus
here is absolutely the word you know
trying to do too many things is
exhausting too oh yeah you know on top
of everything else it's enough to get
out of debt you don't need all these
other distractions
it's a little bit of the problem we've
got with a whole bunch of things in our
culture today people's inability to keep
their eye on the ball to stay and play
through to have some grit to stick with
something all the way through and finish
it up and um you know I want work life
balance but I want to spend 40 hours a
week on my screens so no I think you
need to get off your stupid screens and
uh actually look in the eyes of your
family actually be present physically
with your family
um and then not wonder why relationships
are bad because you're not because you
suck at them right and then one of the
things that we see in in this case here
is is we Prospect as opposed to digging
deep like we're going to invest right
it's like our investment strategy that
you've taught for decades it's slow and
steady wins the race it's disciplined
yeah but you're drilling to the core
we're not just skimming the surface
that's right we're not strip mining
right and so the serial entrepreneurs
can fall prey to that to go well I'm
going to try this because this could
strike but I'm going to do this and
hedge my bets over here maybe this will
strike and as opposed to digging deep to
get that oil like we're going to commit
and go deep and that's where you see
long-term success financially
relationally your health everything the
reason I can smell this out is because I
used to do it right like I mean I'm 23
years 24 years old buying real estate
like crazy hand over fist and I almost
in the middle of all of that Finance 25
000 worth of
quarter machines to put at the market to
pump air into your tires yeah when they
first started charging for air
I thought it was the dumbest thing in
the world and I thought this is going to
work and I almost stopped what I was
doing because I'm a Serial entrepreneur
and add as I can be right and stopped
doing a successful real estate thing
that was working and went and bought air
machines that's how dumb I am yeah by
the way those things never work when I
need air can never get one that works
Dave I don't know about that I bought my
own machine not my fault because I
didn't buy it so you have to turn turn
your complaints into the department you
don't need right really wow